um
the last time we talked we had discussed
that boozy was you were related to boozy
and then i talked to boozy
and then i brought it up to him and he
was like
yeah i think he was like yeah my auntie
told me like you don't know that you're
you know i don't know you guys are
cousins or something right
and he was like i [ __ ] with him but
there's just some weird
there was like some weird beef [ __ ] i
don't know but that that neither of you
directly had with each other but it was
just some
i don't know have you guys had any sort
of
conversation we actually seen each other
you guys finally saw each other
and i and and mind you not only are you
related to him but he's also boozy and
and you're from baton rouge
and he's the god so talk about that
interaction how'd it go man
oh you know he was in the airport
in on atlanta about to fly out here by
the fly
and i seen him and i was like
yeah i got a highlighter you feel me of
course and we just we just ran it and
got some
just like clarification on like what it
was and what was it
um this is a lot of history between like
baton rouge and just like
people in general plus like tbg
you know him he used like i wouldn't say
he was tvg but
it was the same thing tvg embedded as nt
was basically the same thing so it's a
lot of history with them and i wasn't
tvg
like me and g got started playing tvg in
like 2014.
so tbg was already a label that existed
yeah like it's been like you signed with
them in 2014.
i wouldn't sign is just you guys became
a part of this yeah and so
there was a split between badass and tbg
i'm assuming
way before way before we came and got
involved i got yous
yeah like like we probably was the last
ones they ever like
become tvg like even on the dude
um contrail he was a tvg before us
so that was really it it was like some
[ __ ] that you really
weren't a part of yeah so you guys are
solid
no good do you i mean i'm assuming that
doing a record together might be
out of the question still maybe
[Music]
he'd have to work that out with the you
could i mean no
i sent him a record hey man that'd be
crazy